[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause] [Music]
thanks to morning brew for sponsoring
today's video
fasten your seat belts because we are in
the middle of the biggest energy crisis
in the last 50 years but you already
know that everyone is paying a fortune
to have electricity and gas in their
homes and in some countries the price of
gas has tripled but that's not the worst
of it if you're watching this video from
central europe in countries like germany
or the czech republic your biggest
nightmare is not that they will keep
raising the price of gas even higher
your biggest nightmare is that plain and
simple you won't have anything to heat
your home with this winter to give you
an idea at the time of making this video
germans were rushing to buy electric
heaters amazon germany is already giving
out month-long waiting lists to ship
electric radiators that's right
radiators are in 2022 the equivalent of
what toilet paper was in 2020. i know
what many of you are thinking this is
nothing new in the fall of 2021 we were
also talking about a natural gas crisis
prices had also shut up two phenomenon
came together
years of disinvestment in fossil fuels
and a rise in demand for gas
skyrocketing prices followed but this
year is different we have to add the war
in ukraine and the sanctions on russia
in other words the current scenario
could be summed up in one sentence every
man for himself by the end of this video
you will understand the three most
likely scenarios we could be facing and
yes the last one really is concerning
and there'll be some of you who say well
i don't live in europe why do i care
about all this well you had better worry
because this crisis is growing and it's
already affecting countries as far away
as pakistan we are about to enter one of
the most uncertain winters we have ever
experienced the gas crisis can have all
kinds of consequences consequences as
crazy as this one
could there be a beer crisis czech
breweries could be stifled by gas
shortages we could really run out of
beer sorry guys video's over so the
question we're asking today is could
europe really run out of natural gas
this winter how does this affect other
countries what are the exact figures of
the crisis and what can europe do to
avoid an apocalypse today we're going to
answer all of these questions but first
let's take a look at some history before
we do that if you're watching this right
now and you follow visualpolitik it's
because you to a greater or lesser
extent care about what's going on around
you you're interested in knowing what's
going on in the world right if i'm right
we are absolutely sure that morning brew
is something you'd be into morning brew
is a free daily newsletter a five minute
shot of news items that are actually fun
to read and informative it's the best
way to start the day for example they
recently talked about the credit card
problem in the united states and how the
total amount of outstanding credit card
debt claimed to a staggering 890 billion
dollars they also dedicated an article
to how remote working is affecting the
coffee shop business in some parts of
the united states such as florida and
new york it's really interesting so if
you want to get informative and witty
coverage of the news that doesn't waste
your time subscribe to morning brew even
better it's completely free and it takes
fewer than 15 seconds to subscribe click
the link in the description below to
subscribe to morning brew today and now
check this
out can russia cut off the gas
could russia really cut off all the gas
supplies to europe the answer to this
question is no but that is to say it's
almost unthinkable that russia would
ever cause gas supplies 100 however
there was one very big exception to
begin with let's ask ourselves another
question what is natural gas used for
gas saves three main purposes to
generate electricity to generate heat
for certain industries and to power
domestic heating
[Music]
to give you an idea gas accounts for
around 21 of the energy mix of the
entire european union however not all
countries have the same energy mix for
example in finland gas accounts for only
seven percent of the mix the rest of the
energy comes from renewable sources and
nuclear reactors in countries like
poland and the czech republic we're
talking around about 17 the czech
republic supplements with nuclear power
and poland has coal however in germany
they are close to 26
[Music]
and you may ask why well because in
germany they wanted to close all their
nuclear reactors and reduce coal
consumption the vacuum left by these
energy sources has been filled with
renewables and natural gas but wait just
a minute because this is only part of
the problem
[Music]
regardless of the energy mix of each
country there's only one area in which
natural gas is irreplaceable for example
blast furnaces and steel mills can only
be fired with natural gas there are a
lot of industries that run on natural
gas and not only that 40 of the heating
systems in the whole of europe run on
natural gas that is no matter how many
alternative energy sources we want to
use gas is essential to have to heat at
home and i know what some of you are
thinking especially those of you who are
watching this video from warm countries
well it's not that much of a problem
europeans can buy some extra blankets
this winter and problem solved
although have you ever spent a winter in
the czech republic it's easy to get to
minus 15 degrees celsius that's five
degrees in fahrenheit or other made up
temperatures it's no joke spending a
winter without heating is simply
unimaginable and unless you've been
living in a cave almost all of 2022 you
already know that most of the gas we
consume in europe comes from mother
russia take a look at this map
overall russian gas accounts for 40 of
all gas consumed in europe there are
countries with less dependence for
example the spaniards and the italians
will pay much more for gas this winter
but they will have gas why because
practically none of it comes from russia
however there are countries where almost
100 of their gas comes from mother
russia but of all the countries with
problems germany takes the cake not only
are they particularly dependent on gas
they are also dependent on russian gas i
would also like to make a special
mention here of poland poland is one of
the few countries in europe that took
the problem of dependence on russian gas
seriously and built a pipeline with
norway before it was too late thanks to
that they are now much better prepared
to deal with this crisis but we'll talk
about that later
[Music]
the truth is if putin cuts off all the
gas germany and many other countries
have a problem the other question is is
it really in his interest to do so the
answer is that in theory it is not to
give you an idea energy exports account
for more than 60 of all government
revenues in russia so tinkering with
supply could be very dangerous for the
survival of the russian government
turning off the gas tap at current
prices would cost russia tens of
billions of dollars while also
accelerating plans by affected countries
to end any significant supplies coming
from that country in the future
europe is by far russia's best customer
and that's not all russia cannot change
customers overnight the gas fields are
connected by pipelines to europe and
there is no time to build connections
with other countries like china or india
nor can they send it by ships and that's
because well almost all of the gas
fields are on the arctic coast good luck
sailing a liquefied natural gas vessel
in the middle of winter in the arctic
ocean in other words without the money
receives for gas the kremlin can no
longer finance the ukrainian war neither
that nor its own running costs and
you'll say okay so that's the end of the
problem right putin is not going to cut
off the gas matter solved well no not at
all check out this next graph
what you see here is the price of
natural gas ttf futures it's basically
the reference used for each of the gas
negotiations each country buys gas at
different prices in any case we could
say that the price of gas is shot up
everywhere actually we can make two
readings firstly russia is more
interested than ever in continuing to
sell gas at prohibitively high prices
secondly with such high profit margins
russia could still reduce the amount of
gas it sells and still make a gargantuan
profit in this way putin kills two birds
with one stone on the one hand he
finances his war and on the other hand
he puts europe on the ropes where to
sign so the question is not whether
putin or not will cut off the gas but
how much is he going to reduce the
supply by 20
50 80 as you can imagine nobody can
protect the future but we can make an
estimate here how
we can calculate how much money the
kremlin needs to balance its books this
year from there we can use the price of
gas futures as a benchmark the more
expensive the gas is the more russia
will be able to reduce its supply of
course this serves a very rough estimate
but the exact prices at which gas is
purchased cannot really be known and at
this point i know what some of you are
thinking do you really think that putin
is so evil do you really think that a
serious company like gazprom is going to
break the contract as signed for years
this is business we are talking about
and yes you guys are right gasprom is
not going to say we want you to stop
selling gas to you because we want you
to be cold this winter vengeance is mine
no we're talking about a world of
serious people in these environments
they resort to excuses do you want an
example i'll give you one
one fine day this summer was surprise
the turbines of the nordstrom one gas
pipeline stopped working oh by the way
who do you think provides the parts to
make these turbines work well the
turbines are siemens brand but parts
made in countries like canada but with
the sanctions on russia it's gonna be
very difficult for germany or canada to
send those much-needed parts we might
have to renegotiate those sanctions
might we germany and that's when weeks
later we come across news stories like
this
russian gas again flowing into europe
via nordstream one pipeline however this
pipeline is only operating at 20 of its
capacity at least that was the case at
the time of making this video in any
event in a few months this percentage
could be increased as you can see we are
talking about a very complicated
situation for europe and the question is
what can be done well lucky for you guys
we're going to look at that right now
[Music]
stocking up for the harsh winter
before we go on let's give you some
numbers to show the magnitude of the
problem we are talking about here in
2020 the european union imported 394
billion cubic meters of gas or bcm so
that's 394 bcms of this amount in 2020
174 bcm came from russia in 2021 it was
somewhat less around 150 bcm the
question now is how can europe get 150
to 170 bcms of gas from other suppliers
will both the international energy
agency and the european commission have
a plan and the first part of that plan
is fill the gas tanks for the winter you
see all countries have gas reservoirs to
cover peak demand now those reservoirs
are not even enough to cover a quarter
of the winter demand and it's not easy
to fill them either to give you an idea
at the time of making this video europe
had only filled 66 of its gas capacity
naturally each country fills its tanks
at different rates and once again poland
takes the medal it is one of the few
countries that has already filled its
gas tanks the rest are going crazy
looking for gas supplies from anywhere
while at the same time calling for a
reduction in consumption
[Music]
according to the international energy
agency if all europeans agree and reduce
their thermostat by one degree this
winter they could reduce between 10 and
12 billion cubic meters of gas that is
between 10 and 12 bcms is this a good
idea yes but it is not enough 12 bcms is
small potatoes compared to the 174 bcm
target we were talking about before so
what's the next step to look for
alternative gas suppliers let's see what
other countries sell gas to europe
here's another graph
as you can see there are not many
countries and remember that most of the
gas that reaches europe comes through
pipelines you can't build a new pipeline
overnight norway already has its gas
plants working at full power their
pipelines literally cannot deliver more
gas another supplier is algeria in
recent months italy's eni has negotiated
an agreement with algeria's suntrash for
how much for four billion cubic meters
of gas that's good but it's not good
enough and it won't arrive in time
either wonderleading has traveled to
azerbaijan to negotiate more gas
purchases but once again they will not
arrive in time before winter building
pipelines can take years many years in
other words there's no time for that so
what other alternatives are left check
this out
every man for himself
imagine a methane tanker that is a huge
ship carrying liquefied natural gas it's
about to reach the coast of pakistan
from the port you can see it approaching
the horizon however just a few miles
from arriving it turns around why
because at the last minute the captain
got a call
what i've just described is a real
situation it has happened and not just
once but several times in the year 2022
the gas market has become a real turkish
bazaar think of it this way there are
two ways to buy natural gas one is by
pipeline and the other is by ship in
this case we are talking about liquefied
natural gas the gas that comes by
pipeline is negotiated through large
contracts and there is always
politicians involved for example mario
draghi himself when he was still prime
minister of italy was present at the
signing of eni's contract with
soundtrack normally we're going to talk
about contracts for gigantic amounts of
money and in the very long term some can
extend to more than 10 years the
advantage of buying gas prices in this
way is the prices are super low
[Music]
lng can be up to three times more
expensive than a pipeline of gas so
since europe already has cheap gas it
bought hardly any ships however now
europe is desperate for gas and it has a
hell of a lot more money than other
countries like for example pakistan
we're in price war in this case we're
not only talking about big contract
signs between politicians all kind of
independent gas traders are also
involved the slogan is whatever the
others pay you the europeans will raise
it by 2022 belgium is estimated to have
increased its lng purchases by 650
percent meanwhile pakistan's purchase of
lng has dropped by 72 put another way
europe is buying a good part of the gas
that would otherwise go to asia and
where does this liquefied natural gas
come from well mainly from the united
states but that's not the only place
europe is buying gas from all sorts of
countries qatar of course egypt nigeria
etc the question is will there be enough
to supply the 174 billion cubic meters
of russian gas well frankly it's kind of
complicated
remember again depending on the year
russia sends between 150 and 170 bcms it
may be a little less but basically we
have to fill a shortfall of between 150
and 170 bcms at this point it is
estimated that euro could buy an extra
50 bcms of lng from other suppliers
[Music]
to do the math we saved about 10 bcm by
lowering the thermostat we bought an
extra 50 bcm from other suppliers at 60
bcm in other words we still need russia
so what else can be done to replace
russian gas well to go back to other
sources of energy that seem to have been
forgotten
germany to reactivate coal power plants
as russia curbs gas flow
germany rethinks nuclear power exit due
to threat of winter energy crunch and so
once again the question is is this
enough to avoid a harsh winter well the
truth is it's kind of difficult to
predict but we can give you three
different scenarios
[Music]
the best one is that russia doesn't turn
off the tap too drastically let's say
they keep sending 60 or 80 of the gas in
this case the biggest problem will be
the wild rise in prices an economic
problem but better than nothing the half
bad scenario is that russia shuts off
gas a bit more in this case governments
would prioritize households over
industries many factories would have to
close checks would be left without their
beer but they would not freeze to death
the really bad scenario though would be
if russia turned off the tap and would
only sell us 20 or so in that case we
could be in the situation of gas
rationing at home that is it could be
the case that in some countries in
europe the heating could only be turned
on at certain times of the day and at
this point the question now is over to
you which of these three scenarios do
you think we're going to end up in is it
possible to find new gas suppliers
before next winter you can leave me your
answers in the comments below and as
always don't forget that here on
visualpolitik we release new videos
every week so subscribe to this channel
and hit the little bell button down
there so you don't miss any of our
updates if you like this video like it
and i'll see you next time because i've
got to go and panic by beer
ciao
[Music]
you